we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a very disturbing disturbing
covet conspiracy theorist who called in
listen to this
yo pax what up man total control 871 yo
what's up with the surge from what i
understand the covet is surging again
but why does it always surge in the
communist controlled states the deep
blue states where it's surge surging oh
my god it's surges what can i say i'm
sorry sorry about that you know the the
surge it catches one unawares
and what can i say you know guys like me
over 50
shot free and covet free for some
strange reason i never get sick
so this is what we call
extrapolating inaccurately from an
anecdote
there are tens of millions of people
who have not had covet and some of them
are unvaccinated and the fact that this
collar
didn't get covered and isn't vaccinated
tells us actually nothing about the
pandemic that's so weird it's almost
like the pandemic doesn't exist right
and and so that's what we call
extrapolating too far
he didn't get sick
so it must all be imaginary hey we know
that's crazy talk you know that's a
conspiracy thing surge surge surge
sorry sorry dave uh that was a real
surge that was a real strong surge oh my
god that was oh i think i almost went
blind with that one
oh my god i just surged all over myself
all right so as you can see
these are not exactly the types of folks
that you can really speak rationally
with that guy actually called into the
show once about a year and a half ago
and his talking points were pretty
similar
it's tough to get everybody on the same
page about basic facts when you've got
people who believe stuff like that that
that's where we can leave it we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today won't
even tell you what's on it you'll just
have to tune in to see get instant
access to the bonus show by signing up
at
joinpakman.com and you can use the
coupon code big voting 22 to get a
discount if you so choose